um to answer sudarshan uh if the webinar
is going to be audio based you know the
webinar is going to be uh both Visual
and audio based
if the card we will be getting to the
course fees at the end so we will be
answering all of your questions
um to answer suggestion
uh if you have any other questions uh
please let us know
yes uh sudarshan we will be sharing our
presentation just in a minute
and we also have a YouTube link for
anyone else who wants to watch it on
YouTube
so we will be streaming live
uh yes you can uh join it now yeah we
will honey we will be answering all of
these questions so please bear with us
for the next 10 more minutes
um as we start the program
and we will be answering all of your
questions and also have a discussion on
how
we can use band for Matrix for biology
and discussion about infectious diseases
thank you
okay yes I have a lot of questions in
the chat uh okay abhimanyu
uh sudarshan yes so we will answer
everyone's question and you can
definitely uh ask us any question please
put them down in the chat box because we
will have dedicated time slots where we
will be answering each of your questions
so please keep posting all the questions
that you have in the chat box if you
want us to reach out to you you can
leave your emails as well and if you
want to reach out to us here is our
email ID marketing at Pine dot bio
where you can reach out to me for any
kind of questions and we will be getting
back to each of you and also have a
discussion today with all of you uh
regarding this subject
I hope everyone can see my screen
clearly and
you can hear me also clearly if you have
any kind of audio problems please let me
know right now so that we can help you
out
and you can always use the zoom audio
option in case you are not able to hear
me
thank you so much
for confirming that we just want to make
sure that everyone can hear us
and there are no uh possible technical
disturbances in between
so we have six more minutes to go
thank you thank you sir thank you so
much
it would be great if everyone can keep
uh their microphones muted when our
speaker is speaking during the session
and we will take all of your questions
in the chat box and maybe have a
dedicated time where you can actually
unmute yourself and ask questions you
can just let us know that uh you have a
question so we will be allowing that
time for you
thank you
I guess so we we kind of keep it muted
so that there is no kind of technical uh
problems during the session because
oftentimes with the video running many
people feel it it's disturbing them or
sometimes even the sound can be very
disturbing
but we will try to make the webinar as
interactive as we can and also hear from
your end
thank you so much for understanding
yeah and thank you Muhammad we hope that
you enjoyed today's session
foreign
yes a high Kaiser
in just a few more minutes
and
you can use the chat to ask any
questions you have for our speakers who
will be interacting with you during the
session
and also if you have any questions other
than what we talk about in the session
we have an email ID you can reach out to
and you probably must have received an
email from my end I am deepsha biswas
Community manager at Pine biotech so you
can just
uh reach out to us uh Dr Amira we do not
give out certificate for a free session
but there are several free courses on
our website which I will be sharing the
link to shortly that you can take and
you can uh use those certificates as
well
and uh Noel there are no certificates
for this session but as I again
mentioned uh before you can take some of
the free courses which also come with uh
certificates and you can also use those
certificates and put them in your
LinkedIn profile or you can put them to
your CV as well so we will be talking
about that at the end of the session and
we'll be sharing those links as well yes
I will be sharing the link very soon
um
yes if the car we are going to be
recording the sessions and they will be
emailed to you shortly
so we are going to be uh beginning this
session in a few more minutes
and as we see that everyone else is
joining
yes Jeep so we are also going to be
talking about internship uh so for today
right now as we are going to be starting
we will be addressing uh the topic that
we have decided to talk about today
yes yes Dr Amira we will be emailing you
the presentation if I've already signed
up and registered for the event then we
have your email ID if you have not you
can leave it in the chat box so that we
can get to you
so let us start today's session I will
start by recording it on my computer
thank you for joining again and please
keep your microphones muted and your
videos turned off as we speak and the
chat box is again open for all questions
welcome to this free webinar on
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
in today's webinar we will speak about
bioinformatics for infectious disease
research and present use cases for
bioinformatics analysis methods that are
used in viral evolutionary studies
antiviral drug Discovery as well as the
emergence of drug resistance in
bacterial pathogens
we will also showcase some of the latest
developments of the t-bio info platform
designed for virology studies and
introduced the upcoming omics logic
training programs for those interested
in effective utilization of
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
immunology and microbiology
my name is bipsha biswas and I'm the
omics logic Community manager
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of users that are part of our
biological community managed by Pine
biotech
over the past couple of years we have
seen participants from all over the
world join our training programs take
online coursework and utilize our big
data analysis Tools in various research
projects
what we will discuss today and
throughout this webinar is a result of
hard work by an amazing team led by
company co-founders Dr Alfred Tauber and
Dr Leonid propsky
Dr Taber comes from a medical background
and has extensive expertise in
archeology immunology and biochemistry
of inflammation and has been recognized
internationally for his generous support
of many research projects and
initiatives that support training and
applications in Medicine Dr Leonid
Brodsky is the director of the topper
bioinformatics Research Center at Haifa
and is an expert in bioinformatics and
by statistics he has numerous
Publications in mathematics and
bioinformatics and over the course of
his career has developed multiple novel
algorithmic approaches to biomedical
data analysis the rest of the team you
see here includes experts in
bioinformatics computer science and
training and some of our team will be
presenting today as well
in the upcoming Omens logic program you
will have the opportunity to interact
and collaborate with an international
team of experts specialized in the
application of data science to
biological data sets let me introduce to
the main speakers for today's session
Dr harpreet Kaur is a certified omics
logic trainer an expert by information
who will guide the Hands-On sessions and
assist participants with projects and
Analysis during the program her area of
specialization is in genomics and
machine learning
doctor is a romance logic project mentor
and an expert in Big Data computational
analysis Dr mazumdar has a PHD in
computational biology and over 10 years
of experience working with industry and
Academia
is our co-founder and CEO at Pine
biotech in his current role he has
extensive experience working together
with industry and academic partners that
are applying multi-ohmics integration
and bioinformatics to a variety of
biotechnology and clinical applications
I will pass it on to Elia to talk about
the increasing role of bioinformatics
and data science and infectious disease
research and introduce you to the types
of challenges data analysis data
organization integration and
visualization can solve for biomedical
research projects over to you Elia
foreign
thank you very much time uh my name is
Julia brodski I'm the co-founder and CEO
of pine biotech
and I want to share with you today a
little bit of a perspective of what role
bioinformatics is playing in different
aspects of infectious disease research
and would like to also introduce a
couple of tools that we have designed
and developed for this kind of study to
help understand the relationship between
genomic and omic data in general with
various aspects of infectious diseases
genomics and bioinformatics have
contributed immensely to our
understanding of infectious diseases
from disease pathogenesis or how the
disease develops over time to the
understanding of how disease happens or
what are the mechanisms of interaction
between the pathogen and the host
the spread of bacterial and viral
antimicrobial resistance and antiviral
resistance
as well as the host immune response so
how does our body respond to these
challenges posed by these pathogens
as a result infectious diseases has been
one of the areas where genomic medicine
has changed the way we interact with
pathogens to detect them characterize
them and develop treatments and
prevention strategies for these
important diseases
and so as a result this the application
of bioinformatics to omix data has
substantially Advanced our ability to
detect study and treat infectious
diseases and the achievements came as a
result of a close collaboration or an
increasingly close collaboration between
computer scientists and biologists
placing bioinformatics I believe at the
center of these current advances in this
domain and so I hope that in this
presentation you will also be able to
see and appreciate the role of
bioinformatics and how diverse
bioinformatics applications in
application to infectious diseases are
so there's an increasing need in
mastering bioinformatics skills to be
able to conduct such research
so the omics data that is now regularly
being used to study viral genomes DNA
variation host gene expression protein
abundance and composition properties of
microbial communities they really
require very different types of
approaches to dealing with this kind of
data to be able to effectively study and
mine this data for patterns
and really understand the pathogens and
their interaction with the hosts so
today we'll take a look at several
examples of these kinds of data sets and
how they apply to key examples that we
will discuss
so the role of bioinformatics in general
and in the context of infectious
diseases is really to allow researchers
to access process analyze and visualize
these kinds of high throughput data and
so I will introduce several examples of
how this was done successfully by
researchers that are studying viral
infections like the Ebola virus outbreak
in West Africa covid-19 pandemic as well
as microbial pathogens that cause
tuberculosis and malaria we will briefly
touch on viral genomics and evolution as
well as the analysis of gene expression
patterns for detection of significant
genomic variants as well as important
aspects of the microbiome and the viral
so really not just individual pathogens
but whole communities in a host that are
being studied to find important
associations with disease susceptibility
as well as outcomes
in the last 20 years availability of
genomic data has led to an increasing
understanding of how cells function at
the molecular level and has allowed us
to understand some of the major causes
of deadly diseases that affect Humanity
around the world
with the current rise in viral outbreaks
and their deadliness there's a major
focus on developing tools data
repositories and data sets for better
understanding of the emergence
prevention and treatment of infectious
diseases so in fact you can see here
that
in 2020 uh the coronavirus disease
obviously has captured the attention of
researchers around the world placing it
as one of the prominent causes of death
but nevertheless many of the diseases
that you see here listed have some kind
of a pathogen behind them for example
you can see here tuberculosis HIV and
AIDS malaria
meningitis and so there are a lot of
different hepatitis there are a lot of
different
infectious diseases
diarrheal diseases that are listed here
that are leading causes of death
importantly we can see how the field of
virology and microbiology has developed
over time and you can easily see it in
this illustration where we see in 2002
one of the first review of viral
metagenomics
where the application of metagenomic
sequences was highlighted to study
viruses and the communities of viruses
that they live in and eventually leading
us to 2020 where there has been an
explosion in Publications all based on
analysis of sequencing data
so what's happening and this is an
important Trend that I wanted to
highlight is that sequencing
Technologies and the ability to analyze
genomic data has led to an increasing
abundance of structured data sets that
are easy to navigate to find data and
mine that data to study important and
happening right now events right so if
previously it took a long time before
identification of a particular challenge
to then finding the right data or
developing that data set or a database
and then eventually coming with
conclusions about the analysis of that
data today that's happening almost in
real time so regularly researchers
studying covid-19 are generating data
that is not necessarily as a result of
an experiment but just generating data
from patients and from different types
of experiments that are being conducted
regularly placing it into repositories
that we all can access and applying
these tools to extract some meaningful
patterns that immediately can lead to
insights about how is this pandemic
developing over time and what are some
of the important features or
characteristics that we can focus on to
prevent treat or understand this disease
better
and importantly I think that this trend
over time has highlighted some of the
important ways that we are starting to
think differently about these pathogens
not only as individual elements
individual genomes but really also as
communities of microbes of
microorganisms viruses and bacteria
that live together and interact and
surround us every step of the way and so
there has to be a greater appreciation
for the way that the host and the
pathogen interact leading to emergence
of such deadly diseases as covet 19.
and making some parts of the population
much more susceptible to be infected and
lead to much more deadly outcomes so
really it has led all of this data and
all of these
uh data sets that have been collected
have really changed the way that we
think about viruses bacteria and other
pathogens and so one important emergence
of uh this kind of an understanding has
been the appreciation of the viral which
is the part of the microbiome and
constitutes all of the organisms that
inhibit it inhabit us so the might the
microbiome includes uh all the
microorganisms that inhabit the human
body that include bacterial and archaeal
organisms as well as the microbiome and
other members of the male fauna such as
protists and metazones
studies of the viral are really in their
infancy because it has only become
possible recently to see the viral in
large sequence data sets using
bioinformatic tools that can detect
relationships between viruses despite
this High nucleotide sequence diversity
so in fact the size of the mammalian
biram is not even known Although our own
cells are outnumbered about tenfold by
our bacterial microbiome the number of
viruses may be tenfold higher still
human feces alone contain
over 10 to the 8th or 10 to the ninth of
viruses per gram
Additionally the mammalian virum is
continuously updated through Rapid
evolution of viruses and through
exposure to viruses in the environment
or in other mammals so one of the
leading reasons why we can now
appreciate the role of individual
pathogens as well as study them as
communities in their natural environment
is the ability to sequence and
understand the variability of genomic
data present in a given sample
so let's talk a little bit about one of
the major technologies that has made
this possible and the technology of
course is next Generation sequencing
now the way next Generation sequencing
is used is also changing it has been
highly expensive and prohibitive in
cases but today the size of the
instruments the ease of use of those
instruments as well as the cost
association with associated with
producing high quality data have led to
an explosion in Next Generation
sequencing data one of the challenges
with Next Generation sequencing data is
that it is still large and requires
specifically designed tools to be able
to extract meaningful patterns and find
associations between short sequences
and phenotypes and so let's talk a
little bit about what are some of these
associations and what kind of
metagenomic data are available to study
infectious diseases
to study metagenomic data and to
understand the composition of this data
there are really several different
techniques that could be used at the
sequencing stage
first we can speak about targeted
sequencing in other words we can select
a particular organism or a type of an
organism
we can prepare specific
adapters that Target sequences unique to
that individual organism or group of
organisms amplify and then study
sequence variation knowing what we are
going after
the second approach is the amplicon
so amplicon sequencing
is typically used to amplify a
particular region and that region might
be useful to understand variability
between different organisms present in a
sample
for example amplicon sequencing is
hugely popular with metagenomics
when we speak about bacteria the 16s
ribosomal RNA or other genes have what's
called hyper-variable regions or regions
that allow us to study taxonomic
composition of samples without having
the full genomes sequenced and assembled
which is a major challenge because so
many of the genomes do not have a
reference
another approach is to sequence the
whole DNA or RNA
so we can extract all of the DNA or RNA
present in the sample sequence it and
then within all of that information to
look for particular types of genomes or
genomic elements and characterize what
we have and quantify how much of it do
we have
so these are very different approaches
that allow us to extract very different
types of information from a given sample
for example one of the challenges with
targeted sequencing is that we are not
accurately characterizing how much of
that particular element do we have in
our sample
at the same time with the whole DNA and
RNA sequencing it becomes very expensive
because we are sequencing everything and
we are assuming that a lot of what we
are sequencing is not going to be useful
if we are focused on the study of a
particular pathogen
so to understand how to find the right
kind of data or maybe how to sequence
the right kind of data and then how to
analyze that data with the right kinds
of methods we really need to go behind
some of the Black Box methods that are
typically used in bioinformatics to
understand the logic behind these
analysis methods and apply that logic to
a few different examples that will
illustrate what this type of data can
give us
for example
to study microbial and viral pathogens
several different types of sequencing
have been applied with different types
of analysis Pathways or Pipelines
to understand different aspects of the
pathogen or the microorganism that is
causing a disease
to the community within which it is
causing that disease so what other
microorganisms it interacts with
to then potentially understanding how
that pathogen responds to different
challenges applied to its natural
environment and those challenges could
come from treatment
from the immune system or from
competition with other pathogens within
its environment
so this kind of sequencing has been
applied to both viral outbreaks to study
them in real time and understand how
they are changing over time as well as
to kind of persistent infections
including HIV
malaria tuberculosis and other pathogens
that are regularly treated and therefore
they are highly likely to evolve and
change the way that they interact with
the environment because of those
pressures so here we have two examples
one speaks about viral outbreaks
where we can take a direct clinical
specimen and within that specimen that
comes with all of the present organisms
that are there we could either amplify
for specific viral sequences and
therefore study the specific changes in
the virus genome using Sanger sequencing
or using a luminous sequencing
we can take all of the present material
align the virus reads or align all of
the Reeds to a virus reference genome or
a database of viral genomes and then try
to understand what what kind of viral
populations are present in a sample
in this case we see a number of
different types of application
applications of metagenomic sequencing
to study different aspects of pathogens
and how they interact with the human
body so for example we can use it to
identify a specific strain out of all
possible strains to detect and really
characterize what does that strain look
like
we can also look for specific mutations
or genes that are known to be associated
with different phenotypes including
resistance to different treatments and
drugs
and looking at the composition of
different viral sequences present in a
sample we can even predict the emergence
of a particular group of those viruses
that will become dominant and will have
an antiviral resistance
characteristic to them
we can also look at the microbiome so
instead of looking at individual
pathogens Look at Full communities where
we can compare healthy and sick or
healthy and different types of
phenotypes and really compare and
contrast those conditions to understand
how at the genomic level we can find
different types of taxonomic
organizational Representatives so
different types of taxonomies that can
help us understand how these communities
might be related to a phenotype or to a
condition and then finally we can look
at transcriptomic data so we can look at
the immune response or the response of a
cell to that pathogen to understand how
that pathogen modulates the response as
well as to understand what kind of basic
inflammatory processes and immune
response pathways are activated and
whether they are effective or what other
types of maybe adverse response that
might cause
so to really look at the variety of
insights we can gain from such genomic
data we really need to understand what
this data looks like
so here I have an example of what the
sequencing produces so the process of
sequencing is really the process of
generating short reads here individual
lines that you see are short reads that
typically are mapped to some kind of a
reference and the mapping process is
very dependent on the quality of these
reads of the sequences within the each
of the short reads that we have here and
the abundance of those reads so the
higher the abundance the more confident
we can be that we are finding very
accurate signal and then we can trust
the changes that we observe in the
signal to understand what kinds of
mutations or variants are emerging in
the sequence
and also what kind of variation we
observe between different potential
representatives of this kind of sample
[Music]
you have muted
okay
thank you
okay so when we have this raw sequencing
data one of the major challenges is to
really apply the understanding of what
kind of variation we have to a detailed
understanding of what this genome
actually contains for example in the
case of the novel coronavirus we need to
understand the properties
of the different sequence elements or
genomic elements that encode for
different types of genes or
protein-producing genes or even helper
genes so sequences that don't
necessarily become proteins but they
assist in the process of replication so
from going to go from the raw sequence
reads to be able to say something
meaningful about what we observe and the
variation that we observe we really have
to capture the data have reference
information about reference genomes and
what those reference genomes code for
and then we have to piece together the
different information that we have about
the pathogen itself how it interacts
with its environment and what is the
response of the host that we can measure
and quantify
so let's talk a little bit more about
some of the analysis methods that are
useful for this kind of genomic and
transcriptomic data
so today we will speak about four
different examples of methods of
analysis that are useful to be able to
study these kinds of viral and microbial
infections and what and let's think
about what they can produce as we
discover associations and patterns in
such data
so we'll talk about analysis methods and
tools for genomic and transcriptomic
data analysis of host pathogen
interaction
for example methods to study
relationships based on local and Global
multiple sequence alignment what's
called MSA
phylogenetic analysis and evolutionary
studies used for genome ancestry and
population Fitness
chemical and structural implications of
sequence variation mapped on pdb models
or models of proteins that we know of
in-house pathogen interaction and
treatment response Based on
transcriptomic data
to speak about these different tools we
have prepared different sections on the
t-bironmental platform that you can
easily explore and quickly apply to
different types of data sets using the
t-bion for platform that has a visual
interface so let's go to that platform
beepsi if you could please post the link
on the chat
I'm going to open the chat
okay so please go with me to
server.t.bio.info
thank you biebsa
what you see here is a section of areas
of analysis really this represents
different types of
methods bioinformatics methods to
understand and study such
variation at the molecular level so
please let me know once you're on this
link and it has opened up for you you
can just put number one in the chat or
say okay or yes I'm there and I will
know that at least a few of you are
there so we'll take a little look at
some of these tools
foreign
okay excellent thank you very much so I
see that many of you are here so now
just to explain anyone that is
interested in using some of these tools
in the context of research or education
you're welcome to request an account you
can actually get a free account as a
demo to understand how this tool works
but I'll briefly showcase today several
aspects of this type of research that
could be done on the platform using a
visual interface and then I'll
transition a little bit to go behind the
scenes and show you how these tools work
so first of all what you see is a few
different sections right here and one
important one is this access form so if
you are interested in using this tool in
the future after the session please fill
this out fill out this information and
we will reach out back to you by email
to understand what exactly are you
looking for
for some of you you might be our
previous customers or participants from
different programs so if you do have
your login information you're welcome to
log in
okay uh thank you beepsa
okay so let's take a look today at
several different aspects and I'll just
first highlight those sections here so
all of you can easily find them so we
talked about genomic variation
transcriptomic variation analysis of uh
phylogenetic relationships or phylogeny
and then also host passage host pathogen
interaction
so we have here several different
sections for example here under
phylogenetic tree and you can open up
here an example
in this example we'll briefly speak
about how you can go from raw sequencing
reads to understand the phylogenetic
relationship between sequences and these
sequences could be genes or whole
genomes
we will also speak briefly about how you
can conduct an analysis of viral host
path host pathogen interaction
so here you can see an additional level
of highly detailed molecular data that
allows us to understand emerging
mutations and characterize Fitness of
virus populations
we will also speak about
viral quasi-species
that allows us to look at point
mutations
defective viral genomes and also to link
that to different types of genomic
variation at the phylogenetic level
finally we will speak about
transcriptomic data analysis so using
analysis of rna-seq data we will take a
look at how you can understand
response to treatment response to
pathogen infection and characterize the
immune response by looking at Pathways
and genes that are involved in that
response
so first of all let's look at what
genomic data looks like and how we can
find any kind of variation within this
data
so if you don't have an account you
won't be able to do this at the same
time as I do but later on if you are
interested in repeating this demo on
your own we are happy to send you a demo
account so you'll have a login and a
password to come in and do exactly the
steps that I do we're not going for the
sake of time we're not going to do it
together because we have a lot of
participants but in the future after you
review the recording you'll be able to
do that so please request uh your demo
account by filling out this form if you
would like to do that
okay what I'm going to do is I'm going
to go into this section for mutation
variant
and I'm just going to give you an
example how you can go from genomic
sequencing so sequences of DNA or RNA
mapped onto the reference genome so here
we use bow tie two to map to the
reference genome and then producing
results in a visual format so as a
result of mapping on the reference
genome I'm going to get a Sam or a bam
file and that Sam or a bam file is going
to show me what is in the reads
so let's take a look here I'm going to
load the jbrowse application for the
results of this Pipeline and the results
will be loaded in such a way that I can
easily navigate them and find what's in
my data
okay so what's important here is to be
able to understand what this data
represents so let's zoom in a little bit
and we'll kind of take a look at what we
can see here
as you can see each sample represents
millions and millions of reads and these
are individual reads that we can look
into that have a sequence with a T C and
G
and those sequences are mapped onto a
reference genome so in this case this is
the human genome
with variable coverage
allowing us to find variation or changes
that are significant from the reference
genome so for example here we can see
this green little marker and this marker
represents a snip or a variant that we
can study so we can look in and we can
see what is this variant so we can for
example zoom in a little bit more here
okay and we can see what this variant in
is now one of the challenges of analysis
is to be able to map all of these reads
to the reference genome identify such
variation and then importantly maybe
most importantly is to find what might
be the association between this
particular change and some kind of a
phenotype
the other use case here and let me do
another quick demonstration here is when
our reference is one organism for
example the host but our input data we
suspect has sequencing reads from both
the host and the pathogen
so here I'm going to do some
pre-processing on my data and then I'm
going to again map it onto okay sorry
that here I'm just going to go quickly
to another section
and I'm going to perform essentially the
same process I'm going to map on the
reference genome and find the
visualization tool and look at a
different type of a sequence
sequence that was mapped to be able to
identify a particular type of a genome
okay so here you can see again this data
is being mapped and I can see the reads
but importantly when I go into the
results I will be able to find not only
what is in my data but also to find the
individual reads and the percentage of
how many of those reads were mapped onto
the reference genome using such
technique I will be able to identify
potential pathogens from a viral or a
microbial database that I could then
study in a more detailed way
now another section that we will look at
today is a section that has to do with
multiple sequence alignments
so let's take a look right here under
phylogenetic tree
we can look right here what is this
section designed to do
what the section does is load in genomic
sequences and those genomic sequences
contain uh maybe a variety of different
viruses from the same family
or maybe it contains individual reads
from patient samples
and we can then either work with fastq
files based on sequencing reads
or we can align the genomic data to
perform multiple sequence alignments and
understand what is in our data either as
a relationship between multiple
viral sequences for example or as
haplotypes that you can study for
variability
and find association with a particular
phenotype
so this is an example where we can look
at haplotypes
or there's an example where you can
actually look at
I'm going to go back here where you can
look at the specific uh relationships
between viral sequences so using
multiple sequence alignment and then
converting those sequences to amino
acids and then understanding variability
using all kinds of phylogenetic methods
that I'll talk about in a second to
really understand variability between
genomic sequences
so let's take a look at the meaning of
some of these basic analysis methods and
how they could be used to study the
genomic variation
so at the basis of all of these analysis
methods is what's called multiple
sequence alignment and so here you can
see the idea of multiple sequence
alignment when we take multiple reads or
multiple genomes
we make sure that they align to each
other in such a way that maximum
similarity is uh
is on average
achieved between the full sequences
we then identify specific variations and
those could be variations at the
nucleotide level or the amino acid level
and then we characterize those mutations
to understand what types of mutations
are we finding
importantly when we deal with next
Generation sequencing we are going to
find a challenge of characterizing those
changes that only have low coverage
so the higher the coverage it's
important for us to achieve a high
coverage to be able to be confident in
the changes that we observe
once we observe those we can then start
characterizing them by associating them
with a particular phenotype for example
we are not able to hear you
probably
a technical error on your end
um give us a minute everyone
um I guess there is a problem on his end
yeah thank you so much Mohit we'll just
be back shortly
okay so I think uh Elia has uh some kind
of problem on his end which I will be
having a look at so the session is not
over yet
yes hi
yep sorry about that something happened
here with my network let me try sharing
you again
yeah thank you
can you see my screen
yes India we can hit see your screen
thank you
[Music]
okay sorry if my uh Network here for
some reason became a little bit unstable
so again to be able to understand
what process is causing these variants
or what are these variants associated
with
we need to touch on the biology of the
pathogen itself because in each case
with each different pathogen that we're
talking about there's going to be a
variety of factors that we need to
consider
for example when we speak about viral
infections
we have a basic
entry of the pathogen into a cell
with the objective to hijack the host
Machinery to produce viral proteins
assemble them and eventually
produce multiple replicates of the same
virus
now to really go into the detail of this
process not only is the entry difference
between different types of viruses but
also these viruses are not homogeneous
they actually represent a community of
various types of sequences
and so one of the questions is whether
one of those particular types of genomes
that are entering the cell eventually
lead to a variety of the different types
of pathogens that exit the cell and what
are the different immune responses or
strategies that the virus has to adapt
and avoid or evade the immune response
of the host
so when we study genomic variation
for the different pathogens we are
actually thinking of how these
particular mutations that we observe in
the sequences that are captured
represent a relationship between the
ancestor or the sequence that entered
into the host and the present-day
species that we observe and the way to
understand the relationships is to map
the different groups or genomes that we
have into what's called a phylogenetic
tree
this phylogenetic tree can help us map
the differences between genomic
sequences in such a way that we can
associate it with a process a process of
going from a single ancestor to then
dividing up into branches just like a
family tree would
that we can study for variability and
distance evolutionary distance between
each one of our members in the data
and the potential common ancestor that
they might have
so what kind of information can such an
analysis yield
this is an example of a phylogenetic
analysis of the 2016 outbreak of the
Ebola virus in West Africa
here you can see and this has been done
obviously for many other viruses
including covet 19. so here you can see
from 2014 to 2015 we can see one single
type of the original
pathogen that started this epidemic and
eventually split up into multiple claims
and some of those clades were more fit
they were more capable therefore we have
observed them to be more present in
later days and some of them we can now
start thinking about well which
geographic locations were they more
prevalent in
obviously in each one of our Geographic
locations we have different types of
phenotypes for people for treatments for
the way people interact for the
different death rates
for the infection rates etc etc so now
we have an ability to structure our data
and study evolution of the virus
its ability to adapt to different types
of responses
the common origin right one of the
questions could be did it all start from
just one single location and which
location did it start from and which
location did the transfer happen at
as well as the Divergence right so what
might be some factors that contributed
to this highly Divergent phylogenetic
tree at the end of that process
now as I mentioned this type of analysis
is also very effective not just for this
particular case of the Ebola virus but
also here beneath we can see a similar
analysis for covet 19. so for covid-19
in initial analysis was largely focused
on how we can study such type of
variation
between different known species of the
coronaviruses like stars one and Mars
as well as some of the novel emergent
pathogens that we are starting to see
beyond that first characterization of
covid-19 for example in other animals
what might be a potential host Reservoir
that we should be cautious with
so one of the things that we can do with
such information is not only look at
sequence similarity but start looking at
which particular regions of the genome
show us more or less variation
and what kind of consequence does that
variation have at the amino acid level
at the level where it actually codes for
a protein therefore having a functional
capacity
so one of the things that have emerged
from the very beginning is that such
variability in the case of covid-19
was not uniform it was not the same
across the full genome so if you look
down here at this figure C
you can see the nucleotide Identity or
how similar different genomes are to
each other or to a single reference and
you can see the dips right so these are
lower areas that show that there's much
less consensus so they're more Divergent
they're different
and the differences now have to be
mapped to the different
particular proteins that are encoded in
those genes
so probably many of you have already
heard about the spike glycoprotein the
protein that is responsible for viral
entry into the host cell and we can see
that this particular tip happens right
here with the spike protein
and here you can see another dip that is
less than that but also this happens at
the end protein so now we can think
about well what might be the consequence
of such changes in association with
protein function
when we want to understand protein
function there are several ways that we
can deal with that variation ultimately
relying on again genomic data
so we talked briefly about how
nucleotide level similarity can inform
us about amino acid level sequence
similarity when we look at the sequence
similarity we can look at genomic
context or features right so if we know
where this particular genomic element is
being expressed or what is its
functional class or we can compare
Global and local sequence similarity
these can be Tools in our toolkit to
study amino acid variation based on
nucleotide variation found directly in
the genomic data
the second option that we have is to
understand the 3D structure so
ultimately when we have a sequence that
sequence gets translated into an amino
acid sequence because it folds and the
amino acid folding happens based on
physical chemical properties so how the
different amino acids could be put
together into an actual structure that
is going to become functional
now here we also have some tools to
identify different types of functional
elements or motifs that we know and have
characterized in the past we can also
look at the actual structure of this
protein if it is available
and try to understand the implication of
nucleotide variation on the properties
of the overall structure
another method and we'll talk about this
in just a second is to generate High
throughput data so we can generate data
on gene expression for example by taking
out a particular gene or a protein or a
portion of a protein or introducing a
mutation that will cause a stop codon
that will lead to a stop codon and
shorten the protein and now we can study
differential gene expression analysis
which will reveal how the expressed
properties of that protein have changed
after we have introduced that
modification
so really those are the three elements
that we can connect and combine together
to have a full overview of what is going
on
now importantly a lot of this data is
already available online so we talked a
little bit about different tools let's
speak a little bit about different
resources that you can find to
understand
what kind of genomic information is
available and how you can start right
away to develop an idea or a project for
a particular type of a pathogen okay so
let's go quickly to ncbi virus
foreign
please go to go with me to ncbi virus
I'm just going to paste the link right
here in chat
okay please let me know once you've
arrived at ncbi virus
okay thank you Michael if you could
please put in chat that you've arrived
here yes please put number one or number
two
excellent so now that you're here right
the reason I'm saying two is because we
already had our first link which was the
server where we analyzed data and this
is now our second destination the second
destination is where do we actually find
the data
okay so for those of you that got here
obviously you have a quick access to
source code 2 Data but importantly the
data set includes a variety of different
pathogens and here we're just focusing
on different viruses so here we'll
quickly see a number of different viral
sequences that are available so if you
look on search by virus if you click on
search by virus think of any virus
coronavirus influenza hepatitis Ebola
virus so really any virus that you can
think of and just place it right here
I'm just going to place here Ebola virus
just give it a couple of seconds
and you will see that this drop down
appears where you have different
subtypes of that family the Ebola virus
family and here are the different types
of the Ebola viruses
so for example we can see here Zaire
Ebola virus
so once you click on that particular
type you can now see the different data
sets that are available so by looking at
this data
please let me know how many nucleotide
sequences are available
for this Ebola virus
for the Zaire Ebola virus you you should
be able to find on this page how many
nucleotide
sequences are available excellent thank
you Chandra prakash was the first one so
you get a special call out there okay so
2938 so almost 3 000 viral sequences for
Ebola virus for those of you that are
interested
let's take a look and instead of the
Zaire Ebola virus then we can just
remove this and here add another plus
and let's search for Coronavirus
so you can see the corona Verde family
and and now tell me how many are
available for the corona Verde Family
all right great noun poon got it first
so special call out tonight 69
000 sequences uh now who remembers when
did the Ebola virus epidemic really uh
start uh you know as a big concern how
many of you remember uh the Ebola virus
outbreak okay
2008-2016 okay really 2014 is when it
started there have been outbreaks before
that okay so I see Mohit uh Mishra got
the the first right answer there 2014 to
2016 was really the outbreaks it was
started around 2014. now if you think
about it we're in 2020 that's just six
years ago so we've had this ongoing
research of the Ebola virus and the
sequencing uh change really the way that
sequencing was used directly during the
outbreak uh is that first outbreak of
Ebola virus because of several different
reasons so in previous outbreaks of the
Ebola virus like in the 1960s mentioned
here by abir 1970s I think is when it
was uh you had very expensive and highly
laborious uh process of generating those
sequences
and so as a result those sequences
accumulated fairly slowly but in 2014 to
2016 there was also an emergence of
Oxford nanopore sequencing which was
very affordable it was not very accurate
but you could literally take it to the
field and take a sample and sequence it
right there in the matter of maybe a
half an hour so as a result there has
been an emergence of this real-time
sequencing data about a pandemic that
was going on and many many labs around
the world were focused on analyzing
those sequences to extract meaningful
information that will guide the
detection characterization treatment and
prevention strategies ultimately
resulting in a vaccine and not so long
ago an antiviral treatment for the Ebola
virus
as opposed to today right you can see
the rate at which this is happening
right so remember 2014 six years ago
today we're in 2020 so from 2020 from
maybe December 2019 But ultimately in
2020 so we're just talking about a
matter of months we already have almost
70 000 sequences so when we have 70
000 sequences the challenge is not in
generating the data anymore
the challenge is in analyzing this data
to understand what it means and so
that's why I think for any one of us
that is interested in such an
understanding not only do we have
really an explosion of data that is
available on viral genomic sequences on
whole bio projects that give us access
to different levels of information about
both the pathogen and the host
as well as the specific
characterization of even protein
sequences that we can access through pdb
so we're not just looking at the level
of genomic similarity
we're also starting to look at what does
this genomic information tell us about
the variation of key proteins of these
pathogens that actually interact with
the host proteins as well
so here you can see the spike protein
and the spike protein mapped with
mutation frequency based on the analysis
of different types of coronaviruses and
specifically covid-19 compared to low
mortality rate coronaviruses where we
can start to get an understanding of how
different elements of this Spike protein
the ones that interact with the binding
the ones that do Cell fusion so we
really can apply our understanding of
the real world situation with that
genomic data right so combining those
two types of data together and
ultimately this kind of understanding
can have a profound effect on our
ability to characterize transmission
detect when the transmission happen and
how it happened
how we can think about different types
of intermediate hosts and potential
intermediate hosts
as well as thinking about actual biology
at the molecular level where we have the
receptors the immune response and the
interaction with the immune response
tissue tropism so how the virus adapts
to different types of tissues and tissue
barriers to ultimately design different
types of intervention strategies to try
and address the current epidemic now
importantly that we need to link all of
this information to a quantifiable
process and in this case we can have a
quantifiable process of the rate of
mutation linked to our biological
understanding of how the rate of
mutation and the mutations themselves
affect the particular regions on the
proteins that we can study for example
we just looked at the spike protein
one of the regions within the spike
proteins that has the most variability
between the high and the low death rate
Associated coronaviruses is What's
called the receptor binding domain this
receptor binding domain is really a part
of the S1 subunit that is located within
the spike glycoprotein sequence
so it has several different functional
domains and these functional domains
have different rates of mutation so
those variations that we observe at the
genomic level they are happening at
different rates in different portions of
this protein and to understand what they
might mean we can really start taking a
look at the receptor so this is the host
receptor right here that you can see in
the blue is the H2 receptor and you can
have the spike protein actually bind it
now the spike this ace2 receptor
actually sits within the host cell
membrane just like that
and this sodium dependent neutral amino
acid transporter is what holds this H2
receptor in place when the virus Comes
This is the spike glycoprotein it is
protruded from out of the membrane of
the virus and it has this particular
receptor binding domain which is colored
in red here
amazingly we have all of these
structures already available and so
because we have all of these structural
elements available all of the genomic
data that we have can be highly
informative as we study protein protein
interaction
so the interaction between the spike
protein and its receptor binding domain
to this particular protein called H2
okay so I'm going to pause here for a
second and I wanted to see if there are
any questions that I can address at this
time
which I have
um
so we have one from Hindi adeshina uh
please what's the best sequencing
platform for microbiome analysis and do
you have any guide on using nanopore
sequencing platform for 16s rrna
sequencing I would be working on this
for my MSC research
okay thank you for that question
um yeah so you know it's difficult to
say what is the best sequencing platform
because they have different aspects of
uh quality of the actual sequence the
cost which is an important factor so you
determines how many sequences we can
make and also how easy it is to work
with that data so basically there I
would say are three or four different
types of sequencing data that you will
find for this kind of application
there's Sanger sequences sequencing
which is the gold standard for long
sequencing you can have very accurate
sequences but the problem is that you
need a lot of annotation to be able to
produce those there is illuminous
sequencing which allows us to find
really a balance between high level of
accuracy and short reads but it is a
little bit expensive however there is my
seek Illumina my seek platform that
allows us to and is typically used very
popular for metagenomic data analysis so
16s ribosome RNA
where you have a long read about 300 350
base pairs long and you can use those to
capture
one or two hyper variable regions so for
example a V4 V6 V4 v9 you can use
different combinations to study
taxonomic variability
then you have Oxford nanopore and I
would also put pack bio maybe in that
category so Oxford nanopore is very
affordable easy to use the data has
um you know not so it's not such high
quality so you do have a lot of
variability but it is useful to
characterize populations right because
in the case of metagenomic studies
you're not looking at individual
sequences individual genomes you're
really looking at taxonomic variability
and composition so I think that is a
very good platform to use for
metagenomic sequences
yeah
okay
so Noel has a question I'm planning to
do a whole genome sequencing of a
camplayo bacter do you have an
user-friendly platform that may help me
in analysis of obtained data
yeah so what I showed today and I will
give another little example with the
Ebola virus here there are multiple
different ways that you can use genomic
sequences to understand what you have
found for example you might be focused
on as I mentioned phylogenetic analysis
so Divergence of
present-day samples from a potential
common ancestor you might also want to
look at differences between different
types of samples that you have may be
associated with a different phenotype
like their geolocation or resistance to
different types of treatments so
importantly you have to have the data in
certain formats to be able to use these
different types of analyzes one part of
that data is the genomic sequencing the
other part of the data is what do you
want to associate it with right so we
will I'll give here in a couple of
minutes another two examples on Ebola
virus and on tuberculosis to kind of
illustrate what is needed for those
analyzes but yes once you have the
genomic sequences that is a big part of
the story and you can do a lot with that
sequencing already
okay okay uh Elia so we do have a few
more questions uh one that we had from
Dr Malik Jain uh the certificates that
we offer for the program here's a
question regarding that if they have any
traceability like barcode or anything
else
okay
um yeah so we do have a permanent link
for those certificates I will pass it on
to beats in just a few minutes to speak
about the training program that will
start in November for bioinformatics and
infectious diseases where many of these
methods are going to be covered in
Greater detail with access to some
asynchronous material as well as
projects that we have curated to be able
to illustrate some of these methods of
analysis
but right now I just wanted to make sure
that I address the questions about the
topics that I was talking about I see
here in the chat
um okay so regarding
um okay I see here
um
uh I read a few papers regarding your
equivalent one along with H2 receptor
they helped some code an engine
infection can give us information about
that so again there are specific use
cases we will go into much greater
detail about the coronavirus the Ebola
virus tuberculosis malaria some other
pathogens in our upcoming program where
we will take the available data and
actually try to mine that for patterns I
think that the key here is that in the
context of bioinformatics we will not
just analyze published research so how
other people have done something but
will actually take that data and analyze
it ourselves to make sure that first of
all we can arrive at similar conclusions
that they have to understand the logic
of how they arrive from raw data to such
conclusions and then ask additional
questions that maybe they have not
previously asked about how we can take
that research further so I hope that for
those of you that are joined in the
session it's really to give you a
glimpse into what kinds of data sets
what kinds of methods of analysis what
kinds of questions we're going to cover
and highlight and so maybe before we
jump into the program I'll just briefly
complete my slides and I'll pass it on
to beepsa to speak a little bit more
about uh the registration process and
and the different resources
okay so I briefly wanted to mention that
when we have genomic data right and I
already Illustrated the process of
visualizing that data that just the
visualization itself is not very uh kind
of clear because we need also
statistical analysis of that data to be
able to determine which ones of the
different mutations or variants that we
find are actually functionally
significant and that was a major
objective in the process of the pandemic
or the epidemic of the
2014-2016 outbreak to determine
mutations that might be associated with
Airborne infection which in case of
Ebola that has a very high mortality
rate was a great concern
as well as what types of variants are
going to have an impact on the
potentially developed vaccine
so as we will cover in the program we'll
talk about the process of taking those
same mutations that you can see that we
visualized and then doing some
statistical analysis for variant calling
and characterization of the genomic
variants to be able to identify the
mutations that are most significant as
you can see right here this is the
actual Ebola sequencing data that were
later on used in the proteins that were
included in the testing of the vaccine
that was designed for the Ebola virus
now the same type of an approach I
mentioned that data on one side could be
genomic data right we just kind of use
here reference proteins that we have
structures of to understand the impact
of those variants we can also look at a
different approach this is an example of
tuberculosis again we have here
visualization and then characterization
of mutations but on the other side if we
have data about response or data about
emergence of different types of
mutations associated with antimicrobial
resistance we can start thinking about
linking those two data using two
different approaches
one approach is what's called gwas so
genome-wide Association studies
associations of multiple positions on
the genome with a phenotype which
require a lot of genomes right so if we
have hundreds or maybe even thousands of
genomes let's say from tuberculosis and
we have incidence of which groups of
genomes are associated with different
types of treatments and different types
of emergence of a single drug or
multi-drug resistant strains we can find
statistically significant associations
with regions so you can see here either
single mutations or whole regions or
multiple mutations together in different
locations that cause such resistance
now obviously these are just a few
examples and we don't have time in the
context of this one webinar to go
through many examples in great detail
but in the program and in all that we do
what we try to do is take data from
current and peer-reviewed publications
analyze the methods that the authors
have used
to come to the conclusions that they
have published and then to try and
extract
additional data sets and additional
methods to develop independent projects
with our research fellows and so I do
want to mention that the program that we
have been discussing today is really
also uh kind of enriched and expanded by
the research fellows that have joined a
research fellowship and I'll let people
talk about that in a second that have
been able to find very useful case
studies and really look at both
artifacts and signal in the data that
they have submitted on ncbi and other
publicly available repositories to
really develop interesting uh findings
from the different projects that you can
find online now here you can see
uh here you can see some of those
examples for example this is a student
submitted uh project proposal that we go
through together during this upcoming
program and I'll let beep say maybe take
over here in a second to speak about
some of the program resources that we
have prepared for this upcoming upcoming
program called onyxlogic bioinformatics
for infectious diseases so really what I
showed today is just a glimpse of a Onyx
logic full program
that will focus on some of these
different examples of coronaviruses
Ebola viruses rhinoviruses tuberculosis
and malaria causing pathogens to develop
an understanding of how to logically
connect the tools and the data to
produce interesting results that are
going to be of significant value to the
virology community so to speak about
some of the program resources I am going
to pass it on to bisa to explain how to
register for the program and how to gain
access to all of those resources over to
ubisa
uh thank you so much Elia uh let me uh
share my screen here again
okay
so before we start talking about the
different resources I just want to give
you an overview of the upcoming program
the bioinformatics for infectious
diseases
so over the course of the past several
years our team has been collaborating
with a number of academic institutions
around the world that have participated
in content evaluation curriculum review
and project design as a result the omics
logic programs have been thoroughly
evaluated and unknown to lead to
excellent outcomes importantly the
programs are designed to support
students with minimal back by
informatics background including biology
and biomedical studies Majors as well as
faculty interested in bioinformatics
data science and biomedical research
we have designed this program to
introduce the data resources and tools
that you can use to apply
bioinformatics to publicly available
data on infectious diseases in this
program we will understand viral
diversity and its role in epidemic
infectious diseases that keep
re-emerging including zoonotic
transmission transmission between humans
and the process of viral and bacterial
disease development as Elia demonstrated
earlier
we'll learn about bioinformatics
analysis approaches to study viral
genomes and understand the relationships
between
viral streams haplotypes finding
differences in sequence data and seeing
the implications for drug and vaccine
design
you will gain hands-on experience by
analyzing curated data sets from public
domain collections Guided by experts
with bioinformatics experience and
knowledge about virology
the goal of the omics logic program is
to provide training in bio for Matrix
enabling independent research Guided by
mentors and peer example developing a
growing Community with shared passion
for data-driven research and
appreciation of Citizen science enabling
students clinicians and faculty of all
backgrounds to develop novel and
independent research using latest
technology in life and data Sciences
so we will combine online sessions like
we are having one today
then self-guided study materials which I
will take every one of you over in just
a few more minutes for an immersive
experience that has proven to be
effective in our well-known and
respected omics logic programs
together with our collaborators we have
been building a growing online community
of bioinformaticians in training ranging
from high school students to faculty and
researchers in top universities around
the world and in all of our programs
this community of bioinformations
students of biology have access to these
tools which are here so Elia has already
I demonstrated the server T bioinfo
platform and I will also demonstrate a
few of these other platforms and show
you the resources that you will have
access to if you are joining this omix
logic program or any of our other omics
logic programs
so the bioinformatics for infectious
diseases is a two-month program that
will include a review of how to use
analysis tools provide examples of
infectious disease related studies and
then offer support to those interests on
working with public domain data set of
their choice we will meet twice a week
for discussions q a sessions and
Hands-On demonstrations that everyone
can participate in
so let us review the schedule and the
registration process together
so I am going to be
going to the registration link here I am
pasting it on the chat so that you can
also go along with me to the
registration page
so this is the bioinformatics for
infectious disease registration page and
this program is starting on the 9th of
November it's a one month program and
Will Go On Till 2nd December
every week we'll have two sessions and
they will be timed at 9 00 am CST so 9
am CSD is in Indian time 7 30 PM IST and
you can also convert it to your local
time if you are not from any of these
regions which is either the us or in
India
so let us just move down we have a
program overview of what the program is
about and here you can see the entire
syllabus for the different sessions
so you have the different session topics
mentioned here and the different dates
of the sessions so usually these are all
one hour sessions like we are meeting
today where our mentors will give you an
overview of these different topics and
go in depth on the analysis and you will
carry out the Hands-On analysis on your
end as well because you will have access
to the resources which I'm going to be
showing and which also Elia demonstrated
earlier
and we will have different sessions as
you see right here
on these topics and you see that there
are necessary gaps uh between the two
sessions so that you can go through the
asynchronous course materials that are
offered as part of this training program
to help you learn on your own and come
up with any questions that you have
and
so the resources that you will have
access to I will be coming to that one
more time so how do you register for the
program you can click on get started and
there are three membership options which
you can choose from
so the different membership options
come with different benefits so the
beginner options will give you access as
you see to all the different courses
that are going to be mentioned in the
program
it will give you access to the code
playground which I'm going to be showing
in just a few more minutes and also the
interactive sessions and the t-bio info
platform
the intermediate membership option will
give you access to a one-on-one Mentor
session where you can request a mentor
to help you out if you have any
questions and have a dedicated
one-on-one meeting with that expert or
the bioinformatics mentor while the
advanced membership gives you access
to another month like not just a second
December but till second January you
will have access to the platform and the
resources so that you can work on your
own project so I know that I saw in the
chats that many of you are interested in
working on a covid-19 project or a
similar project on infectious diseases
so this Advanced membership would be for
you where you get another month of
access now for students and Scholars and
anybody else who would want uh to join
the program and we think that you cannot
afford we have a scholarship program as
well and I'll be sharing the link
shortly in the chat
so before that let me move on to the
different resources that we are going to
be discussing here
so the first is the server type info
platform we all saw how the server debu
info platform works so you will be able
to gain access to the platform which
will not be a demo access but be an
educational access where you will be
able to use data from public domain data
sets like Elia was talking about earlier
and we will be carrying out Hands-On
analysis so all that Elia has
demonstrated in today's session the
mentors would be taking you step by step
on the different logic of analysis in
these sessions
the second platform would be the code
omics logic platform
so you can still start by
registering yourself for free on this
platform there are a few courses
available and this is our platform for
practicing R and python in your browser
so you do not need to install an RN
python but you definitely can do that so
you have courses getting started with
bioinformatics and I know that a lot of
students who are just learning or
starting to learn about bioinformatics
are also very much interested in data
science so we have developed this
platform where you can easily learn
about data science in the respect of
biological data so you will also have
access to this platform
and you will have access to what we call
an organization page
so here I have just opened a tab on the
courses so these are the different
courses that you will have access to
besides the live training sessions so
you will not only have access to the
program live sessions but also the
courses for your own
um one-on-one learning and self-study
and each of these courses have an
individual certificate
that you can get after you complete the
course
yes thank you so much uh Elia
and I also wanted to talk about the
fellowship program just for the people
who are interested in a
online internship so this is the
fellowship link
and in our research fellowship program
we have students joining us or
participants joining us for three months
or six months research Fellowship
and the focus is mainly on working on
their own projects related to areas like
neuro science
um infectious diseases cancer biology
and more so if you have any inquiry
regarding the same you can write to us
at marketing at find.bio
you will see all of our Comics logic
program comes with again basic or
Advanced and the difference is again on
the different level of access that you
get to the T bioinfo platform here the
advanced license will allow you to use
your own data not just public domain
data use your own data to work on your
own project and you can either do it for
three months or you can choose to do it
for six months that is completely up to
you if you are interested
and here is the scholarship link that I
was talking about that students if they
are interested and they hope that you
know they want to join the program you
can fill it up and you will see that at
the bottom of the page you will have to
provide these details and you have to
also mention that while you're applying
for the scholarship and you have to
mention reference from your college or
university and we will reach out to you
after you fill up this form and you can
also choose the different programs that
you are interested in and write on about
it so this is something that you can
apply for
and as Elia was mentioning and he shared
earlier we have two groups which is the
LinkedIn group where you can join
and we have the Facebook group that also
you can join again because we keep
posting updates there
and as we share the link to our YouTube
channel earlier so we also have our
YouTube channel where you can actually
see all the different videos so we post
a lot of informative videos
from not just our webinar sessions but
also on different topics that you can
explore right here on the platform you
can see a review so this is a review
from one of our project interns who
worked with us on a project in
glioblastoma so you can take a look at
that as well and as I have been showing
earlier this link which I shared is a
list of project examples that people
have been able to do once they joined
one or either of these omics logic
programs so if you scroll down to the
page
you will find that we have a lot of
posters that were submitted and
presented at different uh webinars at
different conferences you can see the
different projects here by one of our
interns who collaborated with two of our
other participants from Sri Lanka and
they came up with a project on sarskov
too so definitely if the car if you're
interested you can do a project on
sarskov 2 as well
then you'll have more projects the
glioblastoma project that I just showed
you earlier
then you have more
projects that you can explore so please
feel free to explore the different uh
projects that are available and that
have been actually independently
developed by participants where we from
Pine biodec and our mentors helped them
throughout this process
and if you are just coming to the
platform for the first time and you just
want to explore the different resources
you can also take a look at our
different membership options as well so
we have a very basic membership option
which is just for dollar 10 USD per
month it will give you access to the TBI
info platform you won't be able to
upload your own data but you will be
able to access all the demo Pipeline and
run from them and also you will be able
to access 12 courses on our platform
from different sections like
transcriptomics genomics
metagenomics and epigenetics so you can
consider this option as well we also
have a specialization subscription which
will give you access to
all the courses all the available
courses on a platform and not just
selective courses
and we also have an unlimited dollar 99
research license so the unlimited
membership will give you access to a one
month research license to the platform
where you can actually upload your own
data that you have generated from a lab
and you can analyze that data and also
have our team help you in that process
so you have these options as well but
again if you want to join the
bioinformatics for infectious disease
program then here is the link and we
will also be emailing you the link to
this program and if you have any
questions related to either of these
resources that we discussed today or any
of the other things that you may want to
seek our help about then you can please
email us marketing at bind or bio and we
will reach out to you
so now uh we will be taking in questions
so uh do we have a question yeah thank
you very much for the presentation I
just wanted to mention that we also have
a feedback form for those of you that
are joining and I would like to provide
us with any kind of feedback I'm pasting
the link to the form here in the chat uh
please do join us for
um our upcoming free webinars so you can
stay on these social media networks to
uh that we've already mentioned on
LinkedIn and Facebook to learn about
upcoming free webinars for those of you
that are on the western time zone U.S
time zone we will have another webinar
for infectious disease research on
Friday in the afternoon so you're
welcome to join that one as well and we
regularly have these free webinars and
workshops online uh that many of you
that I see the questions about multiple
sequence alignment or different types of
data I will be addressing those there as
well so again thank you very much for
joining today it was exciting to see
that so many good questions came and so
many uh different types of analysis
ideas and projects are already emerging
we hope to see all of you in the
upcoming program to be able to go into
these different types in detail and
looking forward to interacting with you
so that we can learn more about your
interests which I hope you will be able
to share with us through this forum
thank you again and thank you bibson for
doing this session and uh
and I hope to
hope to uh you know see all of you in
the near future yes there are courses
about genomic analysis and using machine
learning we have that on the edu portal
as BBC showed there's a a whole section
on genomics
where you can learn about genomic data
and there's also a whole series of
courses on machine learning as well
there's an introduction to machine
learning on the edu portal and there's a
whole series of courses in R and python
where you can actually learn about the
models themselves and you'll be able to
practice right there in the code we are
just going through our program on data
science as well so we'll have that
repeated in the future
again thank you everyone and I hope to
see you again soon
thank you for joining us today
for any questions further please email
us marketing at